[Música]
pablo tenía 15 años cuando lo conocí el
año pasado y al principio no estaba
segura si estaba siendo tímido o
indiferente como cualquier adolescente
pero lo que se soltó un poco le pregunté
que lo que le gustaba hacer y me
contestó que obviamente jugar fútbol con
mis amigos pablo es un chico muy interno
pero se le nota que es un poco travieso
y es increíble cómo a veces subestimamos
todo el potencial que tienen los
adolescentes
él vive en villa maría del triunfo un
distrito emergente de la ciudad de lima
capital del perú allá la vida es
complicada alrededor del 20 por ciento
de sus casi 440 mil habitantes viven en
situación de pobreza y es un distrito
altamente peligroso
pablo ha crecido con imágenes de jóvenes
de 13 años tomando licor en las calles o
de pandillas que someten a la población
violentamente todos los días
un factor muy importante en la vida de
pablo es el colegio y el sistema
educativo en el perú tiene una gran
oportunidad de mejora y mucho trabajo
por delante
aunque el pp y el perú viene creciendo
aceleradamente todos los años la
inversión que se hace en educación es la
menor de toda latinoamérica en tres años
solo precio menos del 0.6 por ciento y
cuáles son los resultados pues
consecutivamente hemos obtenido en los
últimos lugares en los exámenes de
ranking pizza que evalúan a alumnos de
15 años de 70 países alrededor de todo
el mundo en comprensión de lectura de
matemática y de ciencias
así como pablo miles de adolescentes
están a punto de salir del colegio y se
van a convertir en la siguiente
población económicamente activa seis de
cada diez miembros de esta población en
el perú solo contarán con estudios
escolares completos esto quiere decir
que no van a estar correctamente
preparados para desarrollarse
profesionalmente
junto con un grupo de amigos todos
profesionales nos dimos cuenta o creímos
que los adolescentes que nos van a tomar
la posta será en la siguiente fuerza
laboral son la clave para el crecimiento
económico sostenible de nuestro país
entonces diseñamos un taller que duraba
10 sábados en donde iríamos a colegios y
enseñar a los alumnos de los últimos
años sobre gestión de metodologías de
gestión de proyectos con el objetivo que
puedan desarrollar una idea de proyecto
durante el taller
es así como fuimos al colegio de pavle
con la ayuda de unos amigos más y los
profesores empezamos el primer taller el
nuestras expectativas fueron ampliamente
superadas
pablo y sus amigos no sólo estaban
aprendiendo sobre gestión de proyectos
también estaban reforzando habilidades
como la de liderazgo al ahora que tenían
que hacer un trabajo en grupo como la
planificación cuando tenían que
plantearse metas como la creatividad
cuando les poníamos un reto o incluso en
la argumentación cuando nos decían
porque su proyecto era el mejor del
salón
más adelante agregamos un programa de
codificación para que sigan explotando
su creatividad para que puedan
desarrollar un pensamiento sistemático
colaborativo y resistente al fracaso
más de 80 profesionales después y 200
alumnos nos dimos cuenta que se estaba
creando un bucle de valor tanto el
alumno como el profesional estaban
aprendiendo cosas nuevas y reforzando
sus conocimientos y también sus
habilidades de liderazgo
pablo estuvo a punto de dejar el colegio
antes de entrar al taller por todo el
ambiente hostil que le rodea y las
influencias negativas
pero acabe se fue involucrando más y
ahora el dirigió una pandilla con sus
amigos en el colegio pero es una
pandilla de agentes de cambio y pidieron
abrir un laboratorio ideas en su colegio
para poder ejecutar las ideas que tengan
un impacto alguien social que se
desarrollaban en el taller actualmente
pablo dirige un proyecto de reciclaje en
su colegio con sus amigos cuyas
ganancias van destinadas para padres
sueldo el profesor de educación física
cuando vemos atrás hace dos años y medio
nos emociona saber todo lo que hemos
aprendido de pablo de briseida de ni con
los voluntarios los profesores y todos
los que se involucraron dentro del
taller porque todos creemos que no se
trata de ver las carencias de un país o
de criticarlo se trata de darle una
oportunidad a los que van a ser los
siguientes líderes en poco tiempo y que
tanto como tú y yo tienen grandes ideas
y sólo necesitan el espacio y el
conocimiento para poder explotar todo
ese potencial y que puedan crecer como
personas como una comunidad como país o
incluso como el mundo gracias
[Aplausos]